he named his dog which by the way is
about like this big it's almost a horse
uh he named his dog after Bodhi from
Point Break
please everyone welcome Mike
so let's start off with bringing up a
slide that I
used in my presentation three years ago
and this was a breakdown of the Tipping
Point I went
League by year and this was to
understand what was happening in
analytics across the NFL or across the
professional sports ecosystem so to
summarize and to make a very quick gist
Moneyball changed the game in baseball
every team adapted now they have 10 15
people deep in their uh in their
research teams the MBA quickly followed
suit they uh really Advanced quickly
with Advanced Optical tracking so video
sensors are able to see what player is
where on on the court
hockey is sort of had this you know
creating new stats from goals and
assists to more advanced metrics like
core C4 and and Fenwick and all these
you know different types of names stats
that uh that people have created and
that's actually what I'm here to talk
about today is how to create composite
scores in sports and Beyond and finally
what my passion is and where I what I do
on a day-to-day basis I wake up for it
is football stats I work for the uh
NextGen stats team at the NFL we work
with player tracking technology to and
track XY speed acceleration distance
orientation you name it this is at every
tenth of a second so we have millions of
data rows even per game at every level
every game going back to 2016. so today
rather than talking about going forward
from 2019
I would love to actually go backwards
for just a story
so back in the early 1970s
there were a committee was formed and
this was the goal of the committee was
to create a more complete or more uh
reliable metric to say who was the best
quarterback in the NFL
and the goal was to say okay well total
yards gained that's not going to be the
perfect ranking measure and completion
percentage which is ones and zeros is
also not going to be the most valid of
measures so what can we do to get past
Aggregates and averages
so the committee came up with a complex
formula and to break this down even if
it comes out faintly on the screen
that's okay because it is a
truly a
formula with that that is so true to
only passer rating the uh the four
components are completion percentage
touchdown percentage interception
percentage and yards per attempt and the
weights that those four numbers come
combine to make up the past rating score
is takes them into account this formula
included below now what we wanted to do
was get Beyond
just the basic and traditional stats of
what of what has really been around for
for years and years I mean the NFL is
now going on
90 plus season excuse me 100 plus
Seasons
um or 50 seasons of the Super Bowl 100
plus season since uh since the game was
was originally founded as a professional
league so really what today we're going
to talk about and I'm going to use this
as the example of the story is the next
gen sets passing score that we created
last year and released in January ahead
of this the 2021 playoffs and the goal
of the passing score is to make a more
robust more complete and more reliable
metric we also want to evaluate the the
uh the pastor by a League average
expectation we want to isolate the
factors that are quarterback can control
we want to represent the most uh the
features that lead to winning and then
finally we want to account for small
sample size I'm going to leave these
four notes as well I'm going to come
back to at the end of the techniques
that we are going to take to create that
score but for first let's break down and
tell a little bit about you know where
we're you know how I got to even to
stand up here I was fortunate enough to
meet Jared Lander at
what is now eight years ago which is now
incredible uh to think about when I was
working with the Minnesota Vikings in
The Scouting department and I like to
tell the story because I suffered from
first overconfidence then imposter
syndrome and then well I guess we're all
sort of just over that imposter syndrome
hump hopefully but the idea of what I of
where we were in 2014 from the Minnesota
Vikings we were living in Microsoft
Excel we were doing printed out reports
and we were doing analysis that wasn't
repeatable
so when Jared came in he said hey we
have an idea to create a model he said
oh yeah that's just a series of linear
regressions well we have these features
and we want to create a draft model oh
yeah you can do decision trees well what
if we have like a ton of different uh
different stats that we don't really
know what to do oh yeah you could do
random force and boosted trees
my mind blew it was a opening and
eye-opening to the world that we are now
in and eight years ago it was a
completely different ecosystem so today
uh you know uh lee after leaving
Minnesota go on to the University of
Chicago and their analytics program and
then hopped on and joined the next gen
stats uh player tracking team back in
2017 very early on in the process so
with all that said let's go back to a
little bit more of the statistics and
and formula and math side of of things
not as much you know as much as we can
talk about who the best quarterback is
from from now until the 13 minutes I
have left but really we're here for our
we're here for stats and we're for
learning how to leverage data across all
different uh Industries across all
domains and sports is a great test case
for how to do it in other examples so
let's first just by start by saying what
is a composite score well a composite
score is a combination of several
variables or data points or observations
to create one single score of a
dimension of a factor another word for
it could be rating another word for it
could be an index but for this purpose
I'm going to call it a composite score
because I feel like it encompasses
exactly what it's supposed to
methods there are more methods than
listed on this and I can go into detail
significantly on each of them the most
basic is simply just averaging if you
have ones and zeros you've got to
completion percentage if you have ones
and zeros you can average batting
average weighted averaging the weighted
averaging could be using the components
or the the uh the linear weights from a
regression model they could be a
weighted formula that you know that is
uh
could be based off of you know subject
matter expertise that you know you know
that this is two times more important
than this now there are several
different ways of creating those weights
in several different ways to weight
scores but the main gist of it is there
are a lot of different uh permutations
and ways to calculate
I move on to factor analysis because
this is one of my favorite sort of ideas
and PCA is certainly if you've gone
through any statistics class you've
learned about variable uh reduction and
dimensionality and the goal of PCA and
factor analysis can often lead to a
black box like
component let's say you use the first
two or first three components to then
use as to reduce the series of variables
down to three and now you can then put
that into a formula well what if you
just use the first principle component
what does that principal component
actually truly represent it actually
represents the the the fit of it as long
as every possible output
that you are that that you are loading
into the uh as factors the concept is is
that it's just going to take the most
optimal fit
to men to minimize the variance of all
of your outputs so this is to say that
you've found no difference that passing
touchdowns matter interceptions matter
yards matter well rather than take a
principal component or rather than take
regression uh building a linear
regression model where a lot of those
very a lot of those data points are
highly correlated to each other we'll
use PCA to account for perhaps 70
percent oftentimes you'll see in in
metrics like this of the variance in
just one uh and one loading and so what
you can do with that is then take the
the weights of each of those
input feature input variables or outputs
in this case and use those as weighted
averages and use those as weighted
variables so there are again a myriad of
different techniques tips tricks you can
find what we've experienced from
nextgens that's perspective going
through these uh this process year over
year is how much Advanced things you can
do to make it a little bit better and to
clean up some of the bias that's that
will certainly exist
so I'm going to talk a little bit about
standardization normalization and
transformation all of them are data
transformation techniques but the main
purpose is that is really that it is
important both it's a pre-processing
step and post-processing step when
you're cleaning the data it's important
to transform and when you're
communicating that data of the final
results to whatever audience it is
transformation is also key and then from
all of those uh uh goals that are more
tangible are less tangible goals which
there are certainly statistical
techniques to measure reliability and
validity digestibility is one of those
that will definitely be very specific to
your subject matter expertise your
audience who you're trying to
communicate the score to
so let's first quickly run through
standardization which is my favorite
technique I think z-scores are the most
powerful way to uh to truly take a
variable that has two different
distributions two different unit values
yards touchdowns if you want to take if
you want to combine those into a single
average or a single score you take the Z
scores of two assuming the normal
distribution now a lot of times in in
sports we're safe to assume normal
distributions but in other domains it's
very important to understand what
distribution you're working with before
even making any of those decisions
normalization uh you know often referred
to as a min max scalar so rather than
con uh you know converting to Z scores
where 2.35 standard deviations above the
mean might be your population Max right
we're going to set the population Max to
one we're going to set the population
Max
to 1600 like you might have seen on the
SAT we're going to set the min max
scalar IQ goes by the same type of
normalization technique
the idea being is repeated series of
measures normalized can create and the
goal is to create in in this case a
normal distribution
and then finally other transformation
techniques
we have the square root logarithm
reciprocal Square exponential box Cox I
just read you can read too so sorry for
uh being redundant there but the point
of this is the idea is
not every distribution or statistical
measurement that you will see in the
real world is going to Naturally Fit a
gaussian distribution and so what do you
need to do well certain times you can
transform it if you have a very right
skewed
distribution using the square root of
the
square root of the values will actually
create a little bit less skew so there's
different transformation techniques the
goal is to not violate the the spread of
the information so as long as you
maintain the the distance between all
data points you can't add you can
multiply
so here's where I wanted to get into one
of the the discovery we found and
implemented in the next sense that's
passing score as a naive
I wouldn't even call it naive Bayes but
let's call it that for now it is a
Bayesian approach to get Bays into a
formula uh we what originally started as
a solution to solve for the batting
average problem this is actually a
problem that baseball you know
statisticians you could say uh long have
thought about if I go five for ten in my
first three games in baseball I have a
500 batting average does that mean I'm
going to for the rest of the season
finish with a 500 batting average or am
I going to regress to some mean
now how many more at-bats you have also
increases the validity or the validity
of of said measurement and so what what
James of the James Stein estimator does
is it actually shrinks the estimate
based off of the sample size down to the
population mean now there are certainly
reasons to be get more advanced with
this concept the idea of shrinkage to
the population mean is the naive part in
this case because you'd say uh you know
Lamar Jackson his speed is not like the
normal uh quarterback so to regress him
to the population of all quarterbacks
would probably not be as valid in his
measurement but you can start to get
into mixed effects modeling as you start
to get more into the concepts of how do
you come up with the effect of
predicting what
the batting average will be end of
season so this is what uh this
visualization up here sort of shows
1970 baseball this is an example you can
pull out of a textbook
first 45 at bats is the first value the
second value is the is the average of
all their remaining at-bats for the rest
of the season and you can see most
people or most players after the first
45 at bats and for through the rest of
the season regress to their mean and
finally using the James Stein estimator
you can actually see how the shrinkage
works when combining those two so you
have a pre you have the prior of your
the average of your first 45 at bats you
then have the average of the remainder
you can now use the GM sign estimator to
account for based off of the number of
at-bats what is their predicted uh
batting average
this is the actual diagram that was
featured in the 1977 paper
and this is a basic ggplot export of the
next gen stats passing score this is the
goal we wanted to see we wanted to see
that a backup quarterback as they play
starts in the in around the 80 range and
we wanted to you know to skip ahead we
ended up scaling from 50 to 100 so that
people understand Madden ratings because
it's they've seen those those types of
scales before and the concept was we
wanted about the average to be just
under 70 or just under 80. we want uh
really we wanted to to balance both the
how quickly you can get to the max of a
hundred
over a certain a number of sample sizes
and then how quickly uh really does does
that
you know it's almost a shape like this
that you're trying to get to uh for a
composite score where sample size varies
from player to player
so how did we taking all of those
techniques how did we create the next
gen says passing score and how do we do
that with our objectives in mind so the
first objective or the first two
objectives were evaluate performance
relative to The League average
expectation
and to isolate the factors that a
quarterback can control and I sort of
buried the lead in the case that we
actually spent eight months prior to
this working on a neural network model
that essentially had to predict how many
points or how many yards a receiver
would gain if they were targeted on the
play
why does that matter well we're trying
to identify what decision is the
quarterback making
what is the value of that throw when he
makes it so through that we have all of
these data points that are these really
uh almost amalgamations of different uh
different ml models
three years ago I stood up here and
talked about the introducing completion
probability of an ml model and I was
showing simple X and Y graphs of the X
variables and X features to the Y output
of completion probability now we're
looking at upwards of 13 ml models in
production that actually work in live
streams of our tracking data and these
are some of the derivatives that
directly are that are that make up the
components of our next gen stats passing
score you could say that the uh this is
a weighted rate a weighted average of
these z-scores you could say that EPA OE
as uh you know trying to find a number
relative to expectation relative to a
League average that's the uh the most
leading driver of the model and
everything else it was a series of guest
and check to try to find out the weights
that best LED to high correlation high
high correlation to wins High stability
year to year and it had to pass the eye
test
it also had to to represent winning
football games so from the standpoint we
wanted by by grouping these scores into
five or five to ten range buckets we see
a very distinct pattern that the score
end of season had a very strong
relationship with how the team performed
on a win-loss basis
and then we wanted to measure the
validity of our of our metric compared
to the existing metrics out there so Pro
Football Focus which is another Advanced
football analytics service they have
their grades which are a little bit more
subjective you have human Charters
giving twos to negative twos on a per
play basis and they're doing a similar
aggregation and then ESPN's qbr now what
we tried to find is we optimize win
percentage optimize making playoffs
winning season and year-over-year
stability we don't want to necessarily
have too much year over year stability
in the sense of then we might have some
bias and that we only give Tom Brady the
same grade every week but the but the
idea is we we had a delicate balance and
a delicate business case where these are
all questions and all things that
Academia might not have to account for
but we do
and finally generate valid scores at any
sample size of past attempts so this is
the distribution of passing scores uh
both at the game and season level and
you can see that the normal distribution
uh the mean is right around our desired
mean and even if a game even if a
quarterback throws 14 passes he's still
within a range that we can understand
and digest at any sample of past
attempts
and again this is how the distribution
comes out
so to wrap it all up these are the top
10 quarterbacks from the Wild Card
Weekend these are not season ending
these are the Wild Card Weekend all five
quarterbacks that had the higher passing
score won the game
thank you so much
[Applause]